the breath of the wild - teaser trailer
that was released earlier this year has
done exactly what it's set out to do
tease us all zelda theorists across the
entire internet have been scrambling to
uncover the secrets of the meticulously
crafted trailer from deciphering the
strange backwards melody to pinpointing
the identity of the mysterious hand if
you've been here at masculine Nibbana
for very long you'll probably remember
that I also made a theory video on the
castles bizarre levitation that appeared
at the end of the trailer where I
claimed that somewhere in the clouds of
dust seen beneath the castle there were
large mechanical legs obscured from view
what I did not do however was go into
very much detail regarding this
particular theory at all so today my
fellow Zelda people of the internet I
plan on doing so I plan on bringing so
much more to the table to support the
theory that this can only be classified
as a new theory entirely but a task this
grandeur can't be done alone so friends
today I have a very special guest for
you all the fantastic Nintendo black
crisis himself shall be joining us to
discuss this intriguing topic hey guys
just want to say that there is a second
part of this collab that will be over on
my channel so once this video is done
you'll all know where to go and now
without further ado allow us to humbly
present Hyrule's Moving Castle
[Music]
[Music]
as bandit already mentioned Hyrule
Castle may actually have big mechanical
spider like Lakes sprouting under the
surface essentially making it a massive
variant of the Guardian stalkers we see
in breath of the wild give it a weapon
and it could even turn out to be another
divine Beast now sure this does seem
like a cool idea at all
but is there any kind of proof that
would make this seem less of a
completely random idea pulled out of
midair well yes yes there is actually
let's backtrack from the trailer a bit
and focus for now on what we know about
the castle from the game itself simply
navigating around the castles dungeon
like interior and exterior was in and of
itself a different kind of challenge
normally you'd be able to walk around
the world of Hyrule trusting and nothing
more than a directional mini-map to
provide all the details you missed but
the castle had way too much verticality
for such a simple map style a
verticality by the way is the term in
video gaming that relates to the amount
of detail or playable spaces in a game
in regards to the vertical axis instead
of just the horizontal for instance in
breadth of the wilds immersive world map
there's a lot of landmass to run around
in but you can also climb up walls and
cliffs and the sides of canyons to find
hundreds and thousands of secret areas
and collectibles this is what we refer
to as verticality and breadth of the
wild has lots of it this concept is
especially present within the castle
itself from a top-down view it has too
many overlapping areas for the regular
mini-map to be of any use at all so
instead the castle utilizes a
holographic map that allows you to see
links position in three dimensions
easily solving the complex design of its
verticality neat right and where else
have we seen maps like this one that's
right in each of the four major divine
beasts coincidence yeah maybe but that's
not the only oddly specific detail in
the book master works also known as
creating a champion the castle is
revealed to have something even more
interesting within its walls one page
from the book refers to the research
team that the late king rome
orchestrated in order to
create effective measures against
calamity Ganon research teams aren't
free though however the book has
something peculiar that it mentions it
states it was given that the royal
family would cover the costs of all
research but Hyrule Castle itself had a
wealth of ancient energy that was more
valuable than money the castle itself
was brimming with an ancient energy you
say the book describes this ancient
energy as the glowing blue liquid found
within sheikah technology like the stuff
that transfers map data onto links
chicest light the only other mechanisms
to have the unique 3d style maps in the
game the divine beasts also have sources
of ancient energy that enabled them to
live on without any known external
source of power furthermore later on in
the book it seems to pretty heavily
imply that the castle itself has
somewhere inside of its walls a central
control unit that was in communication
with the great plateau sheikah tower in
order to transmit an activation signal
across all the towers and shrines in
Hyrule we also know that at least some
portions of the castles interior such as
the observatory where you fight calamity
Ganon are completely made out of the
same advanced chica material that the
divine beasts and shrines are made of
all of this could be coincidental but we
also know from the creating the champion
literature that Nintendo designed
several unused divine beasts meaning
they absolutely had more in mind than
just the floor ones we find in Game one
that might have been scrapped is the
model hanging from the ceiling of the
hata no ancient tech lab combine all of
this information with the levitation we
see in the trailer and you've got
yourself what could be Hyrule's Moving
Castle I understood that title reference
by the way
so let's switch gears the castle could
be a divine beast and those could be
legs moving the castle off the ground
but what if it isn't the first time this
has happened what if the castle actually
moved to the spot it is now meaning its
original spot wasn't where it is
currently and what if I told you I know
exactly where it used to be let's rewind
once again to before link enters the
castle to defeat game before link frees
the divine beasts even before link
glides down from the great plateau for
the first time rewind all the way back
to the beginning of the game when link
first emerges from a slumber out into
the sunny world awaiting him the first
structure you see the very first one is
one that is all too familiar to many a
zelda veteran well the ruins of it
anyway this building looks incredibly
similar to a rather important chapel
from another game entirely one ocarina
of time in the game if you enter the
marketplace of castle town and head off
to the right you can enter the fabled
temple of time this temple with its
signature three peaked front and unique
theme is the same temple that is now in
ruins in breadth of the wild now it's
true that the building has a few
differences such as the stairs leading
to the building or the massive
cylindrical section towards the back of
the building just not being present at
all in breadth of the wilds variants but
these can easily be explained away by
the fact that thousands of years have
passed in between titles and that
cylindrical section in the back used to
be used exclusively for holding the
Master Sword which has since been moved
into the lost woods but the key
similarities that make this the same
temple from Ocarina of Time without a
doubt are the unique three peaked front
of the building and the musical theme
take a listen
[Music]
so okay why am i spending so much time
talking about the temple of time well
take a look at the temple in its
original state notice anything missing
from the scene yeah it's missing its
castle since the temple in breadth of
the wild was specifically made to be the
same temple from Ocarina of Time it's
only logical to deduce that there used
to be Ocarina of times hyrule castle
nearby now if we were to try to pinpoint
where Ocarina of times Castle would be
based off of the orientation of the
temple of time it should have been
located somewhere relatively close to
the east now if only there were some
ruins or something there to indicate
that this is truly where the castle used
to be oh wait there are in fact there
are ruins all over the place from what
used to be the old castle town there are
remnants of pathways and even platforms
that have since crumbled away and keep
in mind that thousands upon thousands of
years have passed in between these games
meaning any number of geographical
changes could have occurred over that
much time there are more than enough
ruins in this area to justify all of
these speculations if the castle truly
does have innate power sheikah
technology and legs and can move around
the world like a giant divine beast and
isn't it possible that it was once
housed right here on the great plateau
sure it's possible but why did it move
then and why is it moving now
perhaps the castle was moved to stay at
the center point of Hyrule since we've
observed the layout of the land and
explicitly and dramatically changing
from game to game perhaps it was moved
due to the intense battles 10,000 years
ago perhaps it's just a wireless access
point for the other sheikah structures
like a Wi-Fi router it's true that the
major divine beasts were mostly created
to be giant mobile weapons capable of
intensely powerful attacks but on the
other hand some of them like lynx master
cycles zero could have been created
simply to be used like vehicles what we
do know from the breath of the wild to
trailer is that the individual
responsible for raising it is heavily
implied to be none other than Ganondorf
himself in the trailer we see the castle
move
for ganondorf's neck snaps to the side
with that sicne cracking noise his eyes
then come to life with malice heavily
implying a connection between the two
events what could he be planning and
what does it mean for the world of
Hyrule before we wrap this video up I
wanted to point out one last detail from
an original piece of concept art for
breath of the wild what we can see in
the image is a large piece of what looks
like a mountain levitating above the
ground with a certain individual perched
on top and with that cape and armor and
stature the individual definitely looks
like Ganondorf from Twilight Princess to
me if we assumed that this is tied to
the levitation of hyrule castle from the
trailer and also assumed that Ganondorf
was the one behind it then the final
clue we can gather from this image is
what's shown dangling under the large
landmass tentacle-like appendages with
claws at the end just like guardian
stones
whether it's labelled as a proper divine
beast or Wi-Fi router or just a you know
normal everyday flying castle there are
so many possibilities that emerge from
the mystery surrounding Hyrule Castle
and I happen to believe that it's a
mobile divine beast but what do you
think let me know in a comment below
what you thought of this theory and if
there's a detail you think we missed
thank you so much for watching be sure
to like this video if you enjoyed the
content and subscribe if you haven't
already to stick around for much more
juicy Zelda stuff in the future huge
thanks to Nintendo black crisis for
helping out this one and be sure to
check yours truly out in the theory
video over on his channel that's live
right now I'll have it linked in a cart
at the end of the video end in the
description below thanks for watching
guys I hope you enjoy it as always huge
thank you to my fantastic patreon
supporters if you're interested in
getting your name featured up here at
the end of every video check the link in
the description below to find out how
also in the description is the link to
my discord page so if you want to chat
it up with the best Zelda fans out there
follow that link to join up that's all
I've got for you today so as always I
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day
this is Mastana Bandits signing out
[Music]